[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur lcp l'émission par
l'agriculture cuisine alimentation mais
aussi écologique alors vous le voyez sur
ce plateau nous sommes masqué c'est le
protocole sanitaire qui a été arrêté par
l'assemblée nationale
on va bien évidemment pouvoir enlever
les masques tout à l'heure pour déguster
est les bons petits plats de chez
françoise est avec moi cette semaine et
comme chaque semaine pour présenter
cette émission jean pierre montanay
bonjour jean pierre bonjour brigitte
bonjour christian jacob
bonjour bonjour christian jacob vous
êtes président du parti les républicains
depuis 2010 9 vous avez été président du
groupe et l'air ici à l'assemblée
nationale député depuis 13 ans promotion
2007 avant vous avez été plusieurs fois
ministre de la famille des pme de la
fonction publique une carrière politique
commencée en 1995 avec un certain
jacques chirac à qui vous vous et une
grande admiration
plus de 25 ans de carrière politique
facilitée par le syndicalisme en tant
que président des jeunes agriculteurs
car votre vrai métier votre premier
métier c'est la terre c'est l'élevage
chez les jacob on est exploitant de père
en fils alors pour comprendre et faut
aller du côté de vos doigts en brie en
seine et marne
là bas des hectares de prairies et
surtout un cheptel d'une centaine de
vaches laitières mais ça c'était votre
vie d'avant
mais ça peut expliquer en partie le menu
du jour jean pierre et oui brigitte chez
jacob pas de repas son brie de melun ce
sera donc fromage et dessert aujourd'hui
avec un tiramisu
mais pour ouvrir l'appétit de cet
amateur de viande à un onglet de boeuf
ou pommes de terre sautées dans le dos
ou des plats cultiver sans glyphosate
c'est possible après avoir totalement
arrêté les phytosanitaires
ni pogné un même cesse de son chardonnay
le meilleur du monde reportage en bourde
rien dans les pieds dans le plat vous
allez voir comment un producteur deux
élèves désormais en liberté d'artix et
volailles après une vidéo dénonçant les
cages à poules
allez on passe à table tout de suite
cuisine et confidences question la coop
souvent dit que vous incarnez le bon
sens paysan et bien ça m'étonne pas et
votre menu en dit long sur cette qualité
d'abord du bris coup de pouce à votre
terroir et votre ville natale
rozay-en-brie ça ne mange pas de pain et
queen is tente d'ailleurs de mots et de
molain les deux berceaux de ce fromage
et puis en tant qu'exploitant agricole
naturellement vous avez été biberonné à
la viande rouge donc au menu viande
petit message à la filière mais habile
pas de tourner dos qui ont ces terres en
ces temps de crise aurait pu faire jaser
mais de l'onglet délicieux mets pièces
moins nobles considérait d'ailleurs
comme annaba et donc moins cher
accompagné de modeste pommes de terre
bref arpa de paysans d'où votre bon sens
je me trompe
christian jacob ont écouté si ce qu'ils
ont qualifié de bon sens je sais pas je
n'ai pas j'ai pas le renier mais sur
l'onglet je sais que c'est ce que l'on
dit mais je trouve que c'est un peu
sévère parce que pour moi c'est une
excellent de viande plus je ne dirais
pas que c'est une viande longue
c'est effectivement c'est c'est en
dessous du filet puisque vous prenez
laloyaux on a le rhume steak on a le
filet puis ensuite à hong hong à
l'onglet après on à la hanche ce week
end à la bavette qui est qui qui est
encore plus bas mais j'aime bien ce type
de viande parce que les ailes et
goûteuse
c'est de la viande longue donc de la
viande qui se tient et je trouve même si
on peut faire le choix du filet pour une
viande beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
tendre je pense qu'il ya plus de goût
dans l'onglet on va à la bouteille on
peut enlever les masques pour déguster
cet onglet que vous avez donc choisi
pour ce repas on dit souvent que c'est
une pièce de boucher parce que c'est dur
à aller chercher c'est au fin fond du
des entrailles du du boeuf c'est sur
l'arrière si vous prenez la l'arrière
tout l'atout de l'aloyau vous avez le
rumsteck en eau
ensuite vous avez le filet et là vous
avez l'onglet qui qui rejoint sur
l'arrière de l'arrière de la cuisse
et puis juste en dessous vous avez la
hampe bon qui était aussi une viande
longue mais je trouve qui de mon point
de vue moins goûteuse que que l'anglais
et puis après vous avez la bavette à une
partie de la bavette d'aloyau et puis la
bavette de flancher si vous n'allez plus
sur l'avant sans mais l'essentiel c'est
dans l'assiette à tous les repas non non
non je prends de la viande à tous les
repas mais mais j'aime bien être et
j'aime bien
j'essaie alors ils attendent et semble
enfin monsieur jacob qui gère brigitte
trois choses à savoir sur l'onglet c'est
considéré comme un produit type tripier
difficile à détailler en petites
quantités dans le boeuf l'anglais se
trouve uniquement chez le boucher et
jamais en grande surface c'est très rare
l'onglet deuxième chose à savoir se
consomme poêlé ou grillés et surtout
saignant une minute de chaque côté en
prenant bien soin de saisir la surface
et il a bien fait chez françoise
histoire de caraméliser les sucres
d'essayer de laisser le maximum de jeux
à l'intérieur de la viande et puis trois
surtout ne pas cuire l'onglet
directement sortie du réfrigérateur
laissez-le 30 minutes à température
ambiante pour éviter le choc thermique
au moment de la cuisson qui risquent en
effet de contracter les fibres
musculaires et de rendre la viande un
peu dû remplir et plus ce qui est vrai
pour presque tous pratiquement toutes
les pièces de viande d'abord pour
qu'elle soit bien ressuyé donc ça c'est
aussi le travail assorti de l'abattoir
que les
les carcasses que les bouchers savent
eux savent bien le faire et c'est vrai
que c'est une déesse de boucher cuisiner
l'onglet enfin où la viande vous êtes on
vous voit souvent me sens mieux à table
que sur les fourneaux mais ça ça peut
m'arriver messi est ce que vous êtes
chasseur
oui donc vous avez l'habitude quand même
de j'imagine un peu de déco et de
dépouiller we will à la chasse que ça
c'est aussi une tradition familiale un
jeu c'est dur ne devrais pas le dire
maintenant mais il ya peu prescription
j'ai dû commencer à chasser avec mon
grand père comme on le fait souvent dans
le temps d'examen je pense que à moins
de 10 ans je devais chasser on n'avait
pas le droit alors le permis oui mais je
fais partie de cette génération ou en
fait on n'a pas passé termine j'étais
sur la dernière 76 puisque j'ai eu mes
16 ans le 4 décembre 76e et j'ai dû
chasser le 5
on va vous chasser mais vous gardez le
gibier vous le préparez mais c'est pas
vous qu'il cuisine et donc qui ne suit
pas et vous aimez qu'elle gibier à table
puisque vous dites que vous êtes plutôt
rabelaisien que quelques chefs j'aime
j'aime bien le sanglier le sanglier en
ragoût cuit et recuit avec des bonnes
pommes de terre
c'est un bon plat en sauce bon c'était
un peu au corps mais en fait je vous ai
je préfère ça oui une gigue de chevreuil
ou de biche isoler les faisant les ouïes
les pigeons des pigeons des pigeons
ramiers
au moment où ils vont manger dans la
plaine ils vont manger les petits
poivrons les on peut le on peut les
chasser en prolongation en weezy bhl là
vous avez des sites très bon parce
qu'ils sont bien gras à ce moment là
c'est le pigeon c'est vraiment à
l'échelle faveur travail et de pigeons
aussi c'est une belle viande est alors
cet onglet il est comment alors il est
très bien fait et comme vous disiez à
juste titre il est bien cuit ce n'est
pas toujours c'est pas facile sur la
viorne la cuisson est parfaite parce que
c'est effectivement cette particularité
il faut arriver à caraméliser sur le
dessus et après d'après ces bleus ou
quoi pratiquement exactement dire mais
l'avion est enseignant mais chaud
intérieur et spécialités que vous aviez
quand vous étiez petit fin quand vos
parents cuisiner c'est c'est eh quoi il
y avait beaucoup de plats en sauce
étaient des plats traditionnels français
c'était le vol aille parce qu'on avait
la ferme ma mère avait des poules les
canards le lapin aussi on avait tous les
tous les animaux de tous les animaux de
la ferme
la charcuterie parce que enfants il y
avait le nez levé les cochons c'est une
base ferme laitière mais on est levée le
cochon en toi le cochon qui faisait la
charcuterie cas il faut à peu près tout
mais beaucoup de beaucoup de volailles
poulets poulets canards
les oies aussi est plutôt à la broche à
la cocotte
non la cocotte le bon le le poulet temps
en temps une rôtie mais en retisse
thouars mai mais plutôt avoir plutôt à
la cocotte un bon coq au vin voilà faut
prendre un vieux coq mais bien cuit mais
c'est quand même quelque chose de
délicieux alors on va voir si vous êtes
vraiment incollable c'est le quiz
j'ai pas cette prétention alors promis
quiz sur la chasse 1 qui est à mon avis
assez facile pour vous qui êtes chasseur
et qui traquait les gibiers insolite à
déguster
laquelle de ces drôles de bêtes est
interdite à la chasse à le ragondin b le
loir gris c'est le castor et des
l'écureuil gris trois espèces on incite
plutôt les chasseurs à les tuer pour en
débarrasser la nature il n'y a pas de
problèmes de biodiversité puis un des
animaux ici dans cette piste qu'il faut
protéger
l'ordi l'écureuil gris mais jeu à part
le ragondin jeu des chaussées aucun des
autres alors non alors c'est le castor
la castors sont doivent en avoir
beaucoup nom qui est injuste bon ils
bénéficient d'une protection totale on
en recenserait 15000 aujourd'hui mais
jusqu'au xviiie siècle on se régalait de
ceux ci sont aux castors bon alors des
gens tirent les ragondins mais parce que
il y en a trop et puis ils détruisent
dbrs et ça j'en ai 26 mai on les mange
pas apprécié sa ce nom vous et ça existe
on peut retrouver des pâtés de rock pour
votre pilote alors deuxième coup et on
vient de le voir vous aimez les produits
tripiers
lequel de ces abats n'est pas consommée
dans le boeuf à kayes est baissée revel
c'est pense des bonnets l'ap en somme on
le
sur le boeuf on la fait pas oui jean
pierre va pas les infos on peut manger
la pente à cet âge et sincère la panse
de brebis
oui mais on mange aussi dans la cervelle
qu'on ne mange pas on mangerait servait
de moutons de porc de vos merdes adobuzz
j'ai pas bien compris pourquoi parce que
peut-être qu'elle était trop gros cet
état mais elle est considérée comme non
comestible à guise la panse de brebis à
oui ça c'est bon c'est bon
votre marché vous vous le faites le
dimanche le samedi vous avez deux
manches et les producteurs ça veut dire
province le marché à provins en principe
tous les
tous les samedis va gros soucis voilà
mais mon règle générale je suis tous les
tous les week-ends à provins et le
samedi je vais faire mon marché le
samedi matin et vous êtes chez mon
boucher je vais maraîchers maraîchers
qui est un producteur
le cal qui est qui dans l'aube on est on
est très proche de l'eau quand on quand
on à provins
je marchais canton les hommes politiques
sur un marché on est accaparé dont il ya
donc non je devais 2 alors je n'y vais
pas il ya une période je ne vais pas sur
le marché
c'est les périodes d'élection tractage
tous les collaborateurs m'ont interdit
de faire ça parce que vous tombez
toujours sur quelqu'un qui vous dit abel
et politique on vous voit parce que
c'est des ex donc en règle générale je
l'envoie promener et on me dit si tu vas
sur le marché - des élections tu vas
perdre des voix
donc je vais pas sur le marché mais mais
j'ai des militants qui sont et qui eux
sont présents pour tracter mais sinon
j'y vais tout le restant de l'année
et j'aime bien parce que l'ambiance de
2,2 de contact c'est sympa puis on est
dans une petite ville tout le monde
connaît tout le monde vous avez votre
liste de courses c'est oui oui ma femme
me fallait comme le contrôleur entend
rien oublier parfois gueuler non mais ça
peut arriver d'oublier des coûts vous
êtes quand même attentif à consommer en
circuit court
le bio également ou pas nécessairement
j'ai rien contre mais c'est pas c'est
pas un critère de la proximité beaucoup
plus manger ce que l'on connaît à voir
là la traçabilité des produits je suis
j'y suis attaché j'aime bien acheté à
maresché que je connais
mais après j -c bio c'est bien si ça ne
l'est pas c'est pas grave et acheter des
fraises en plein hiver c'est pas votre
trip
non non sa saison à la saisonnalité à la
saisonnalité et puis à me faire
conseiller quand j'achète les fruits jde
qu'est-ce qu'il faut prendre aujourd'hui
y est plus mûr quoi alors en france on
sait que l'europe a occupé une large
place est particulièrement en politique
c'est là que se nouent parfois des deals
que se fait la petite et la grande
histoire c'est la brève de comptoir
alors christian jacob on vous a demandé
de réfléchir à un souvenir politique
autour d'un repas lequel vous est revenu
il y en a un qui est amusant qu'il
semble peut-être le plus lu marque le
plus marquant mais je sais pas ce qu'il
y avait dans l'assiette qui était drôle
encore que c'était là la campagne des
présidentielles de 1995 avec jacques
chirac
et il ya cette période de noël où les
sondages étaient catastrophiques pour
jacques chirac je rappelle qu'il ya une
période janvier où il était attrait et
demi dans les sondages d'edouard
balladur était à plus de 30 il y avait
20 points d'écart et claude
claude chirac fille de jacques chirac
appelle pendant les fêtes en me disant
il faut qu'on organise un déplacement
agricole faut qu'il soit sur son terrain
qu'ils soient qu'ils sont à l'aise et c
est donc on décide d'aller faire ce
déplacement en normandie non non non
c'est trop facile la comaga et on était
à lens on a fait plusieurs exploitations
à côté de l'aigle etc
puis le soir un repas alençon faua côté
je sais plus très bien où est là le
dîner avait avait lieu dans un grenier
et dans le dans le grenier
ben oui parce que c'est au-dessus d'une
étape vous fallait une grande place à
une grande salle aménageurs et donc oui
mais on avait dans une ferme son époux
lui faire guinée dans la ferme et donc
fallait en europe l'espace ap la bombe
aurait donc là il y avait je sais pas 50
60 je parle
il y avait il y avait du monde et
jacques chirac président est le
président et le dîner et il y avait moi
j'étais à une table avec vos confrères
des journalistes à l'époque et un moment
jacques chirac se met à relever la tête
et puis il faisait à tête et chirac
quand il faisait la tête il avait ses
mimiques à se pincer les lèvres la
regarder comme ça pour tous et donc tout
le monde était persuadé vos confrères se
disait il ya eu un mauvais sondages et
cetera
il ya un autre sondage qui est tombé
qu'est-ce qui se passe il fait la gueule
donc j'essaye d'expliquer que mais non
mais que tout va bien et qu'on va
remonter etc
et puis quand même je le dis à claude
zidi coup tu vas devoir du journaliste
en train de dire ils me disent tout ce
qui fait la gueule ce qui a et donc
claude va le voir elle lui parle à
l'oreille se redresse enfin clin d'oeil
ça bon tout va bien
et en fait on y en avait une choucroute
qui avait été servi rongé de la
choucroute l'assiette est évident et la
f1 il avait plus rien et personne venait
le servir parce que nous sommes du côté
des questions et son assiette et c'était
un bon et donc ils ont ramené une
deuxième assiette des chirac a retrouvé
le sourire tout allait mieux c'était un
bon
bon vivant jacques chirac vous l'avez
côtoyé beaucoup beaucoup notamment au
salon de l'agriculture on a dû faire
j'ai dû l'accompagner
tu es un des premiers records une
quinzaine plus d'une quinzaine de fois
je pense qu à tête de veau avec lui
alors oui oui on aurait pu faire la tête
de veau il met
mais c'était j'ai cru que c'était sympa
aussi de d'être sur une une viande
grillée puis on m'aurait dit que c'était
un peu caricatural si j'ai pris alors
vous parlez plus que moi moi je vais
parce que oui oui je vois ça mais il est
délicieux effective et puis il était
très bien qu en mai pour le dire en
chair faire ça aux chèvres françoise on
pourra le remercier effectivement moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est de savoir c'est si
vous parlez politique à table quand vous
étiez petit à la maison n'ont pas trop
non par naïma une famille qui étaient
engagés police non mais mes parents
étaient de droite très très chiraquien
mais pour une raison simple c'est
agriculteurs et c'était pas j'étais pas
de côtés de deux de mes parents
n'étaient pas sur une famille avec un
engagement gaulliste en fait
l'engagement ils étaient chiraquien
parce que on considérait que chirac
savait défendre des agriculteurs et ce
qui s'est toujours vérifier moi domaine
responsabilité agricole c'est à chaque
moment notre histoire quand il ya eu des
crises agricoles on en a connu je sais
pas combien
et à chaque fois qu'il y avait une crise
les dirigeants nationaux on se
réunissait
et puis il y en a toujours un moment
qu'ils disaient bon on va aller voir
chirac et que chirac était bon mais
j'étais trop jeune à ce moment là mais
qu'il était ministre de l'agriculture
qu'il était premier ministre qu'il était
maire de paris
qu'il était président de la république
les paysans on allait voir chirac et on
avait de l' écoute et on savait que
quelqu'un ne comprenez donc j'étais
lever plus tôt dans ce va tranquillement
politiques syndicalistes au départ il
vous vient douce être envie de s'engager
comme ça l'engagement syndical il vient
de sortie de l'école j'arrête mes études
à 17 ans j'ai bon
l'école me plaît pas je m'y ennuie pour
un mot poli et donc je reviens sur la
ferme mais j'ai envie de j'ai envie de
faire plein de choses et donc je
m'engage peut faire plein de choses à 17
ans et moi dix sept ans j'ai pris une
carte syndicale et j'ai milité syndicat
des jeunes agriculteurs est ensuite
passé par toutes les strates les rangs
président cantonal départemental
régional national et c'est là que j'ai
rencontré jacques chirac en 88 on avait
une crise
une tension un moment de tension interne
un peu dur chez les jeunes agriculteurs
et chirac m'a appelé un dimanche matin
en me disant je vous connais pas mais
j'entends beaucoup parler de vous et pas
nécessairement bien je voudrais qu'on se
rend compte c'est comme ça que c'est fun
et donc je suis
c'est quasiment sauter dans mon costume
et chaussures vernies je suis allé à la
mairie de paris pour la première fois de
ma vie et pour la première fois de ma
vie j'ai rencontré chirac en vrai patron
le voyais à la télé mais je vais jamais
rencontré mais impressionné les là il
meurt très impressionné et il m'a fait
une leçon sur le syndicalisme agricole
et sur le fait que le syndicalisme
agricole devait rester unie terre ne
devait pas se diviser et j'ai pris une
vraie leçon d'histoire du syndicaliste
ce qui était assez extraordinaire parce
que c'était un moment particulier pour
lui
il venait de perdre la présidentielle de
88 la perte sèchement il venait
d'arrêter de fumer
à ce moment là et donc je le
je le rencontre là et et c'était le
début d'une très belle très belle
histoire et après voilà on s'est revus
main souvient en m'accueillant m'a dit
on va se tutoyer parce que je sais que
les paysans se tutoient donc
et voilà comment ça c'est l'histoire
c'est fait avec on va rester à la ferme
et on va on va parler du bruit parce que
je disais que par un repas pris chez des
jacob alors le bris ça c'est un brie de
meaux oui ou de mort non non non non non
non pas goûté et voilà vous pouvez à la
vague de vous pouvez glisser à peu près
sûr donc tous tous les deux une aop de
mais ils sont un peu différent alors les
puristes disent que celui de meaux a des
arômes de sous-bois et d'air et des
tables et celui de melun de noisette et
de champignons vous opiné christian
jacob
c'est à melun ça me l'enlever il a plus
de caractère
il est plus salée le mou les plus petits
il est plus salée et plus de plus de
caractère un peu plus longtemps
d'affinage et dans ce moulin comme on a
merdé annoncé mort il ya des débats avec
jean-françois côté sur le brie de meaux
brie de melun
l'histoire de du bruit c'est pas il n'y
avait pas de fromagerie historiquement
un mot ou hamelin s'est en fait c'était
l'endroit où les paysans venaient vendre
le fromage c'est lé marché ce qui a fait
le brie de meaux c'est là c'est le
marché de meaux où les paysans du du
secteur de la vallée des deux morin de
la vallée de la marne
allez allez vendre leur nez vendre leur
image oui mais même si on a vu un petit
coup de rouge ont été bien la traiter
non parce que c'est vrai que le bris et
en plus à melun qui a du caractère à
l'eau bon j'avoue que ça on va
poursuivre le déjeuner ensemble et on va
parler de notre assiette qui dit
beaucoup de notre politique menée en
matière d'alimentation mais aussi d'un
cri culture c'est le dessous des plats
alors cultivée sans glyphosate sans
insecticide sans fongicide c'est
possible denis pommier viticulteurs en
bourgogne à tout banni depuis 2008 une
conversion difficile mais réussi et qui
pousse son vin vers les sommets et je
sais que vous ne serait pas insensible
reportage à chablis donatelli gloire
c'est en 2008 que denis décide de
changer radicalement sa manière de
travailler sa vigne présent après en un
coup d'oeil on comprend très vite ce qui
a changé vous montre une vigne qui nous
appartient et en conduites en bio depuis
donc ça fait douze 12 ans où on
travaille les sols on voit les toute
verte et une vigne juste à côté de moi
banques et qui est traitée au glyphosate
tous les ans on voit la différence au
niveau du sol on est on est au mois de
février nous c'est ouvert et là le
terrain et mais il est nul mais miley
triste je trouve
las on voit que le sol le sol est vivant
et pour avoir ce seul vivant il décide
de passer de l'autre bord
celui de l'agriculture biologique
j'avais 40 ans
j'avais toute ma famille qui avaient été
touchés par des cancers des enfants en
bas âge on employait cinq six personnes
à l'époque et c'est vrai que bon voilà
on a on a voulu respecter un petit peu
tout le monde de respecter les gens qui
achètent nos bouteilles de façon à ce
que ça soit le plus sain possible
on n'a pas de certitudes au niveau de la
santé savoir si cela a des conséquences
directes mais voilà c'est un choix
personnel
un principe de précaution qui lui coûte
cher vos débuts il a vu ses coûts de
production augmentent et quand il s'est
lancé dans sa conversion est là où on
n'a peut-être pas pris conscience
au départ c'est qu'il faut avoir du
matériel très performant pour faire du
bio il faut être hyper réactif et un
investissement qui est en général assez
importants travaux mécaniques
on a une perte de récolte qui est en
général de 20 % par rapport à un
conventionnelle on en produit 20% au
moins pour compenser les pertes denis et
sa femme ont augmenté le prix de leurs
bouteilles d'un euro 50 cent et où la
commande pour le québec
et aujourd'hui ils ne regrettent pas
leur investissement le bio attire les
consommateurs le bio oui bien sûr a
permis d'élargir leurs marchés un peu
partout dans le monde et beaucoup en
france bien sûr parce que tous les
camistes maintenant besoin d'une
étiquette bio dans leurs rayonnages bon
les restaurants peut-être un petit peu
moins ce peut être pas une première
nécessité pour eux mais les cavistes
beaucoup et de plus en plus de
particuliers si quand il s'est lancé ce
couple a eu du nez
seulement deux ans après avoir obtenu
leur certification bio il décroche le
titre de meilleur chardonnay du monde
précurseur au début ils sont aujourd'hui
on % environ de viticulteurs en
bourgogne à s'être lancé dans l'aventuré
du bio alain christian jacob vous n'avez
pas voté en faveur de l'interdiction du
glyphosate ici au moment du débat dans
l'hémicycle
et pourtant ce viticulteur là nous
montrent que c'est possible en fait de
n'utiliser aucun phytosanitaires et pas
de glyphosate
ça veut dire qu'on peut y arriver et on
peut même faire un meilleur chardonnay
du monde
oui bien sûr peut-être il l'aurait fallu
peut pas nous non tout à fait moi je
respecte tout à fait tous les gels et
les méthodes de culture mais
être dans l'exclusif personne n'interdit
et dieu merci de faire du bio de
supprimer telle ou telle intrants mais
ça n'est pas possible dans tout dans
tous les cas et puis il faut pas en
faire un dogme c'est la pire des choses
variées
je peux vous faire la démo doc moi c'est
donc livossart voilà la démonstration
sur les sols moi je voulais faire
exactement l inverse c'est à dire que si
vous voulez respectez votre votre sol et
donc conserver une belle bonne capacité
d'infiltration de l'eau il faut éviter
ce qu'on appelle les semelles de la
bourse est à dire quand vous la bourre
et votre sol à 25 cm ou à 30 cm vous
placez le soc de charrue passe toujours
au même niveau et donc ça fait comme une
toile cirée ça finit par être très lisse
très dur et donc quand vous faites ça
d'abord vous couper tous les les
canalisations et la terre ne respire qui
sont celles des lombrics des différents
vers de terre et donc tout ça voulait
couper donc vous créer encore plus cette
semaine le labour et le haut de la terre
est très meuble est en dessous c'est
effectivement beaucoup plus dur non
quand il tombe un orage vous avez un
phénomène d'érosion cette terre qui en
permanence travail en profondeur l insa
et glisse dont vous avez une érosion des
sols
vous avez une moins bonne infiltration
de l'eau donc l'eau ravine au lieu de
reculer dans les ententes n'ont pas ce
que vous voulez la voir ailleurs
parce que vous vous coupez les lombrics
y sont partout il y en a besoin
justement de cette aération des sols
pour la transformation de la matière
organique
c'est très utile et si vous voulez vous
passer du labour ce que font de plus en
plus d'être d'agriculteurs vous avez
besoin d'un désherbant qu un désherbant
foliaire davies a besoin le glyphosate
qui vous permet effectivement de pouvoir
réensemencer votèrent derrière avec des
engrais verts c'est-à-dire sont des
plantes qui vont assurer un couvert
végétal tout le reste de l'année et vous
aurez une bien meilleure structure du
sol avec une technique sans labour que
vous l'avez avec une technique de labour
or pour être sûr du du sans labour vous
êtes obligés d'avoir recours à un
herbicide donc faux de vous demanderez
la prolongation du glyphosate il faudra
avoir un produit de substitution est là
aujourd'hui il y en a pas et puis on est
dans différents secrets des contraintes
ce qui ce qui est assez invraisemblable
on a parfois cette capacité en france à
interdire des produits donc à créer des
contraintes spécifiques à nos
producteurs alors que nos concurrents
n'ont pas ces contraintes je vous
prendre un exemple soit un autre sujet
un produit qui est le ledit veto at il
ya quelques années a dit méthode c'est
un insecticide qui est maintenant
d'ailleurs interdit partout en europe
mais que où la france avait été avait
été précurseur et donc il était utilisé
sur les cerises ces attaques de pucerons
sur les cerisiers
donc on a une attaque de pucerons le
diméthoate est interdit donc cette année
là que c'était il ya 4 5 ans vous n'avez
pas manger une seule cerise française
en revanche la consommation de ce qui
apparaît telle arrière des cerises qui
étaient traités audi méthode personnes
les mêmes règles pour tout le monde et
puis avoir l'intelligence l'agriculture
on travaille sur du vivant on n'appuie
pas sur un bouton la chaîne s'arrête la
rhodésie tu dis c'est cancérogène
probable c'est ce que seuls les comme
les questions de santé publique vous
voyez les chances que vous mettez dans
votre voiture là aussi tous les
comment vous vous dites il faut faire
attention avec ces études elles sont
controversés mais je dis simplement
d'abord les agriculteurs ont fait des
efforts énormes de diminution des
intrants et c'est une évidence pour un
agriculteur pour pour des raisons de
coûts - imad intrants ben moi ça lui ça
lui coûte ça lui coûte cher donc il a
intérêt à le faire et on les diminue et
on les diminue grâce à une hyper
technicité d'ailleurs cet agriculteur le
disait très bien sur le bio il faut être
très technique mais aujourd'hui un un
pulvérisateur ces appareils et qui
permettent d dépendre les pesticides on
a divisé les doses par 3 par quatre par
rapport à ce qui était fait il ya 25 ans
il ya trente ans et ça c'est la
technicité des agriculteurs et la
modernisation de leur matériel est ce
que votre passé de syndicaliste agricole
ne joue pas dans ses prises de position
que vous avez aujourd'hui quand même ça
passe là bas c'est à dire qu'on parle
toujours mieux de france alors vous avez
hésité sur le bio alors qu'aujourd'hui
tous les hommes politiques disent pris
le bio c'est formidable à vous avez
l'honnêteté turballe bio oui moi je vous
n'êtes pas complètement fan vous dites
y'a pas de dogme et quand même est-ce
que se passer cet
c'est l'adn de syndicalistes vous fait
pas oui mais ce n'est pas une tare des
paysans à notre culture c'est même
plutôt pas mal qui se joue et qu'on
donne la parole aux agriculteurs de
temps en temps pour parler d'agriculture
parce que on entend parfois vous avez
fait comme dans les différents secteurs
c'est les charmes et brigitte
connaissait très bien du charme de cette
assemblée
quand les gens parlent soit de sujets
qu'ils ne connaissent absolument pas
qu'ils découvrent mais qu'ils ont un
avis et des certitudes
ac c'est amusant en temps et là
notamment écouter le monde agricole et
il n'y a pas une catégorie
socioprofessionnelle qui a autant évolué
qui a autant une capacité à se remettre
en cause en permanence que le monde
agricole
regardez le niveau de formation des
agriculteurs ce qu'il était il ya 30 ans
ce qu'il est aujourd'hui sur ces jeunes
qui s'installent
la diminution des intrants les
techniques aujourd'hui dutil sur les
soldes analyse de sol c'est à dire que
on va voir des gps embarqué pour m
calculer des doses d'engrais que l'on va
mettre donc donc ça c'est ton
agriculture d'enfance on voit bien qui
se dessine vers le bleu ou vert le 0 de
l'ifo êtes vous
vous dites il faut quand même aller vers
ça mais pour des raisons simples c'est à
dire moins on m'aide à 30 personnes
envie de manger du glyphosate à la
petite cuillère le matin et personne n'a
envie d'augmenter ses coûts donc les
agriculteurs et le fonds des substituts
louis un modèle économique qui
s'équilibre et se noyèrent c'est le
consommateur aujourd'hui qui nous pousse
à aimer les noix et matic non oui et les
agriculteurs eux mêmes
je vous dis pour chaque agriculteur rêve
d'avoir les mêmes des mêmes rendements
en utilisant moins à 30 et et c'est une
logique qui l inverse de toute cette
logique de décroissance qui est une
logique stupide
oddo dernier point notamment sur le plan
de l'alimentation en deux secondes pour
vous pendant deux ou trois éléments de
référence
il ya 60 ans et 3 milliards d'habitants
sur la planète à peu près un peu plus
aujourd'hui on a 7 milliards est bientôt
dans trente ans on sera à peu près 10
milliards
donc pour répondre à cette demande
alimentaire moi je veux bien qu'on
explique qu'il faut produire moins mais
enfin comment on fait donc il ya deux
manières de répondre
soit on met davantage de terres en
culture en extensif y ça veut dire à ce
moment là qu'on lance un grand plan de
déforestation mondiale s'est il n'y a
pas d'autre solution pas bon pour le
carbone ben non je pense pas que je
pense que personne n'a envie de le faire
soit en produit davantage sur les seules
qui existent et donc ça ça veut dire
qu'il faut relancer la recherche
variétale et arrêter là aussi d'être
dans des dogmes en expliquant qu'il faut
produire moins
non on peut produire plus et mieux et en
étant plus respectueux de la
biodiversité de la qualité des sols et
de l'élevage intensif plus et mieux
mais bien sûr on peut à chaque fois
travaillé on le fait sur le bien-être
c'est un autre sujet sur lequel on
pourra pas y voit un bon ballon on va
dire brigitte non je sais pas si ça va
frapper dans ce reportage de j'ai trouvé
que viticulteurs étaient pas très à
l'aise pour montrer qu'il se démarquer
de ses concurrents qui utilisent le
glyphosate c'est pas aussi aux
politiques de d'infuser cette idée qu'il
faut changer pour que effectivement on
n'ait pas l'impression qu'ils aient une
guerre de religion entre ceux qui
utilisent plus glyphosate et ceux qui
utilisent le bilan le rôle du politique
et surtout pas de se substituer aux
agriculteurs ou ça en règle générale on
met dans l'état se substitue s'est
jamais faire infuser 10
la société de créer un environnement qui
soit favorable
et ça c'est notre et c'est la raison
pour laquelle on accompagne et depuis
très longtemps ça date pas d'aujourd'hui
le bio et les conversions en bio bien
évidemment il faut y aller il ya un
marché sur le bio il faut répondre à ce
marché
la pire des choses c'est d'aller
importés c'est pour ça que j'étais
contre par exemple l'obligation du bio
dans les cantines
parce qu'on arrive à des aberrations on
va aller importés de chine des produits
bio dont on connaît absolument pas une
canne est déjà suffisamment solide voilà
donc il faut développer développer tant
que cela ça répond à un marché mais il
faut pas en faire un dogme
il faut le faire avec 2 2 à nice mme
haddad malardé voici un peu moins
d'idéologues et plus de pragmatisme
quand même des voix qui s'élèvent pour
mettre fin à l'élevage intensif
certaines plus fort que d'autres et
c'est le cas de l'association
controversée l214
on en parle et on met les pieds dans le
plat à leur opération commando vidéo
choc un des animalistes comme
l'association l214 multiplient les
actions pour dénoncer les conditions
d'élevage intensif et ça porte ses
fruits christian jacob les industriels
sont obligés parfois de corriger le tir
comme ce producteur 2 qui a abandonné
une partie de ses cages pour laisser
plusieurs milliers de volailles en
liberté c'est un reportage de stéphanie
des pierres et elsa monde à gaza près de
saint brieuc
cette ferme héberge plus de cent mille
poules pondeuses dans le premier
bâtiment 80 mille poules élevées en cage
nous n'aurons pas l'autorisation de
filmer mais dans celui ci des poules en
semi-liberté en 2017
elizabeth et son mari ont retiré les
cages pour créer une immense volière les
poules ont plus de liberté et plus de
place
et dans le système car vous aurez
standard il ya 13 kilomètres carrés on
doit ce bâtiment que l'on a rénové il ya
3000 coule donc ici à des trains elles
peuvent sortir mais là c'est un jardin
d'hiver le jardin d'hiver
le voici face aux préoccupations liées
au bien-être animal et à des
consommateurs qui boudent les oeufs en
cage elisabeth a été contrainte de
transformer son exploitation c'est un
autre mode de travail qui n'est pas
désagréable pas ce combat on est contact
des animaux beaucoup plus que lorsqu'on
avec les cages après nous en tant que
éleveurs notre fouet c'est toujours de
répondre à une demande de consommateurs
mais qui a été poussé par les
différentes associations
ça a été à faire accélérer les choses
voici le genre de vidéos qui a forcé la
main elisabeth même si ces images n'ont
pas été tournées dans sa ferme
mais dans un autre élevage de la région
il n'y a aucune transparence sur la
réalité de ces élevages intensifs c'est
donc par nécessité que des lanceurs
d'alert prennent tous les risques pour
nous informer de l'horreur qui sévit ces
images ont été filmées clandestinement
2019 par l'association l214 qui combat
l'élevage intensif depuis 2008
ce mouvement animaliste est parti en
guerre contre les poules en cage
aujourd'hui l214 estime avoir gagné
cette bataille c'est une avancée qui est
quand même majeur quand on a commencé
avec l 214 en 2008 80% des poules
étaient élevées en cage aujourd'hui on
est à peu près à mi parcours on à 47%
encore de poule qui seront élevées en
cage mais 50% 53% qui sont hors cage
donc c'est déjà une avancée alors que
tout était bloqué on a bon espoir que en
l'élevage en cage des poules pondeuses
ce soit terminé retour en bretagne
ce changement de pratique n'est pas sans
conséquences économiques pour les
éleveurs une poule en semi-liberté mange
plus et pont - duff
elle est donc moins rentables pour la
productrice alors qu'elle n'avait pas
fini de rembourser ses travaux
précédents
elisabeth investi plus d'un million
d'euros pour que les volatiles voit la
lumière du jour
le rideau du jardin d'hiver s'ouvrent à
11 heures le matin et se ferme
au crépuscule c'est automatisés mais
actuellement à cause de la grippe
aviaire
les poules n'ont pas le droit de sortir
c'est comme nous elles sont confinées
en temps normal les poules ont 14
hectares de verdure pour gambader
l'heureux ont donc bien le label plein
air pour elisabeth le changement ne fait
que commencer
elle vend toute sa production la marque
matines or cette marque bien connue des
français va elle aussi renoncé aux oeufs
pondus en cage 10 6 4
alors question jacob quel regard vous
portez sur ses méthodes de ces
associations animalistes à ses vidéos
chocs
la fin justifie t elle les moyens
moi je suis très choqué par ces méthodes
on a parfois des actes très violent on
pourrait parler aussi des attaques chez
débouchés et on en parlera sais je
trouve ça scandaleux ce sont des
méthodes de voyou avec des gens qui sont
totalement irresponsables
moi ça me choque ou plus ça porte ses
fruits il y aurait il s'appelait
toujours en cage
oui si on veut raisonné enfin je veux
dire on peut pas raisonner de cette
manière un éleveur il faut qu'on pense
que un éleveur à coeur que ces animaux
soit élevée dans les meilleures
conditions possibles pour toujours et ne
montera les normes et bien sûr mais on
peut on peut tout caricaturer simplement
non mais je vais vous dire une chose
pour un éleveur l'éleveur pour que son
animal soit au maximum de sa production
faut qu'il ait le minimum de stress et
qu'ils soient dans les meilleures
conditions et après faut être capable de
répondre à un modèle économique parce
que la dame
très bien dit à l'instant c'est à dire
que c'est des investissements il faut
que le consommateur paye davantage il
faut être capable de trouver l'équilibré
économique avec des investissements très
lourds c'est des remises en cause là on
regarde ça tranquillement devant une
assiette c'est très bien sauf que les
gens qui ont fait ce changement je pense
qu'ils ont passé beaucoup de nuits
blanches pour savoir s'il serait capable
traitance animal c'est pas quelque chose
qu'il faut sur lequel il faut veiller
quand même bien de dire non mais bien
évidemment mais c'est lui aussi qui nous
alerte mais c'est le souci de tous les
éleveurs et dire vous ne les avez par
exemple eldia tiens on s'aperçoit qu'on
est plus près de nos bêtes maintenant
mais bien sûr elle s'en était pas rendu
compte et elle n'avait pas initié ce
mouvement à l'est libyen s'est scellée
vidéo qui ont provoqué le déclic chez
elle dit que c'est un cetain
d'accélérateur et mais simplement
comprenez vous et moi j'étais éleveurs
de l'étier j'ai un troupeau j'ai
commencé avec 27 vaches laitières et
j'avais une centaine de vaches laitières
ensuite vous avez à coeur pour que vos
vaches produisent le maximum il faut
qu'elle soit qu'ils aient le minimum de
stress c'est une réalité tous les
éleveurs vous le diront après il ya un
modèle économique un équilibre
économique à trouver et donc il faut ils
vont peut-être mieux avoir une certaine
période
effectivement des poules en batterie
mais au moins avec des yeux qui était
produit sur le territoire français est
une filière agroalimentaire qui crée de
l'activité pour l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens plutôt que de travailler en
importations donc arrêtons de jeter
l'opprobre sur les uns les autres et au
fur et à mesure que parce qu'il ya une
évolution de la société qui est
incontestable parce que les éleveurs
auront aussi à coeur d'évoluer il faut
pouvoir les accompagner mais encore une
fois tout ça doit se faire avec
intelligence et un modèle économique en
face parce que il faut s que les soins
finalement l'inertie et des politiques
publiques depuis des années sur ces
sujets-là de fer et avancer progresser
et évoluer il paye aussi le fait que la
part de l'alimentation dans le budget
des ménages a énormément diminué
c'est à dire que
il ya gpu les chiffres en tête mais en
gros il ya 30 40 ans on était autour de
20 à 25% du budget des ménages consacrée
à l'alimentation
aujourd'hui ça doit être autour de 12 ou
13 12 ou 13%
parce que on préfère acheter un
téléphone faille il yad'autres d'autres
produite convient maintenant qu'on
préfère acheter des oeufs frais des jeux
qui est de poulet bio que dde
oui oui encore que si on regarde sur
lancers que c'est pas le général on a
dénoncé la régénération de tout
simplement pour des raisons de coût
ouais c'est ça parce que tout le monde
n'a pas les moyens de ceux de se faire
plaisir en achetant effectuons des
produits alimentation à deux vitesses
aujourd'hui avec ce qu'ils peuvent
mettre un petit peu plus avec d'abord on
a une alimentation en france de très
grande qualité
donc quand même le rappeler on est un
des pays au monde vous avez le moins
d'intoxication alimentaire on peut se
comparer avec n'importe quel pays du
monde la france contrairement aux
âneries qui avait été racontée à une
époque c'est le pays de la bonne bouffe
on mange bien en france on mange des
produits sûrs on mange des produits
sains avec une filière qui est très
sécure donc faut quand même d'abord
rappelé a ensuite il ya une attente qui
nouvelle la société il faut y répondre
et à partir du moment où il ya un modèle
économique fait confiance aux
agriculteurs pour s'y adapter être
capable de répondre de l'état de la pac
en l'occurrence sa compagne lorient il y
en a davantage senlis les
investissements énormes quand vous
pensez que le revenu moyen des
agriculteurs est à peu près à 15000
euros par an du moyen d'un agriculteur
c'est ça et que vous en avez un tiers
qui sont en dessous qui doivent être
autour de 400 500 euros par mois
c'est ça la réalité du monde agricole et
que vous voyez le niveau
d'investissement qui lie à faire pour
transformer le modèle d'exploitation
bon y'a besoin d'accompagnement et
encore une fois il faut aussi que le
consommateur n'applaudissent pas et 224
et en même temps refuser de payer le
prix de son alimentation ou au site le
consommateur accepte de payer les prix
alors juste produits les produits à leur
juste prix par leur talent vous disiez
pas de dogme
dogme sur le glyphosate est ce que
derrière l214 est justement un dogme
idéologie anti viande clairement affiché
plus que les attaques dans les
boucheries écouter en mai chez les
dingues invraisemblable cesser ces actes
de violence et qui sont revendiquée et
assumée par ces associations
moi ça me joly et vegan serait derrière
salle vous êtes gt 1000 personnes non
mais ce que j'incrimine cesser les actes
de vandalisme que l'on voit de violation
de la propriété privée et d' attaques
physiques
c'est ça qui me choque après je ne sais
pas qui est derrière ça c'est le travail
de à la fois de la justice et du
ministère de l'intérieur dans la
transformation qui s'opère vers des
produits plus plus un plus bio est-ce
qu'il faut que ce soit les grandes
exploitations qui montre un peu
l'exemple qu'ils ont les moyens
finalement elle de changer d'évoluer
d'abord le revenu est pas toujours liés
à la taille d'une exploitation vous avez
des exploitations de très petite taille
qui sont sur des marchés de niche et qui
gagne qui peuvent très bien gagner leur
vie
c'est une évolution avec la formation
aussi deux de nos jeunes agriculteurs
qui ont des niveaux de formation de plus
en plus élevés qui sont sans doute plus
en attentif aux préoccupations de la
société qu'on l'était il ya quelques
années donc cette évolution elle est en
train de se faire mousser je suis pas
inquiet vous trouverez pas une autre
catégorie professionnelle qui a une
capacité d'adaptation comme l'ont les
agriculteurs mais simplement ça peut pas
se faire l'adaptation voilà avec le
couteau sous la gorge
et quand vous tapez sur la tête donc il
faut il faut accepter d'y mettre du
temps et puis d'écouter aussi leurs
contraintes d'écouté des gens qui vous
disent voilà j'ai un million d'euros
investir 6 et gégé un revenu qui est
l'équivalent du smic ou en dessous en
travaillant deezer ou douze heures par
jour c'est ça la réalité du des éleveurs
donc il faut le prendre en compte ça
allait nous reste quelques minutes on a
parlé du péché mignon
tout est le tiramisu alors voilà
christian jacob le temps du dessert je
vois qu'ils se précipitent un chat avec
la norme et moi j'aime bien les gens qui
ne respectent pas la préséance quand il
s'agit de taper dans un tiramisu donc un
totem de la botte italienne le tiramisu
qui sera figurez-vous le deuxième mot
italien le plus utilisé dans le monde
sans doute après pizza reisser j'allais
dire circonstance en cette période de
pandémie propice aux blues et même
davantage car tiramisu brigitte
littéralement ça signifie re donne moi
des forces du morin c'est ce qu'il nous
fallait alors d'où l'importance du café
dans ce dessert qui doit réveiller la
légende urbaine dit même que les
prostituées de naples en danger toute la
nuit pour ne pas s'endormir entre deux
clients salaires voilà d'où vous vient
cet amour christian jacob pour le
tiramisu d origine italienne cacher un
voyage de noces à trévise la ville qui
revendique la paternité de ce dessert
ont d'abord j'adore l'italie à j'adore
cette définition je sais pas si vous
l'avez déjà entendu des italiens ce sont
des français qui sont toujours de bonne
humeur
mais comme toujours le voilà mais dans
un très bon très bon dessert je suis un
peu gourmand alors goûté lundi tout ce
qui menace qu'ils vont c'est le mélange
du café du chocolat louis oui s'il vous
plaît oui alors il est un peu liquide
c'est le mascarpone qui ne serait pas
pris mais le mascarpone c'est le vicieux
très bon et très bon c'est un peu sucré
oui beaucoup bien ya un petit peu de
chocolat sur le dessus est ce que votre
péché mignon vous c'est quand même le
chocolat si j'ai bien compris aussi oui
notre collaboratrice me disait quand
j'ai du chocolat il vient beaucoup plus
loin dans mon bureau c'est vrai c'est
pas vrai que j'ai créée au sein
c'est vrai que c'est à dire cause et
j'allais dire c'est un peu vrai mais on
peut retirer un peu vous êtes du genre à
manger à table et d'un coup oui avait
quand même un nom sur le coup un
chocolat dans la narration etienne et
vous le faites vous même le tiramisu
votre épouse le fait non qu'est ce que
vous aimez dans tiramisu qu'est ce qui
vous plaît dans la texture dans le
mélange mascarpone et puis c'est à dire
le mélange
un peu de l'amertume du café et le sucre
et on a un bonne un équilibre abonnés
qui contient un peu d'alcool du marsala
ou de la mare et aude patron trop pas
trop pas d'accord pas trop non
alors moi j'ai deux conseils à donner à
ceux qui veulent gérer brigitte vous
êtes les rois du tiramisu voilà il faut
prendre des petits biscuits qui
s'appelle des pavés zini qui sont mieux
que les les langues comme on appelle ça
les langues de chat n'ont pas d'âme de
chalets puisque les brosses à huawei les
boudoirs aller à nice et à brossard la
marque c'est meilleur que les biscuits à
la cuillère et il faut toujours trempé
ses biscuits dans un café froid parce
qu'autrement ça le café choual
désintègre un peu le biscuit et puis il
faut vous avez fait votre première
couche c'est à dire vos biscuits et
votre mascarpone
vous le mettez au congélateur une nounou
deux heures pour qu'ils se fichent un
peu et ensuite vous rajoutez la deuxième
couche afin que les couches se
superposent bien voilà on met vos
souvenirs le faire à la maison chopard
eysines et alors ces temps de couvre-feu
la vie sociale est un peu réduite vous
êtes peut-être chez vous ou en
télétravail
nous avons décidé de vous donner
quelques conseils notamment ses de
christian jacob
aujourd'hui pour vous redonner la banane
et pour vous redonner la banane
christian jacob
il faut écouter ça pourquoi pas
[Musique]
[Rires]
alors on est trois autour de la table on
va pas dire qu'ils aient le bon la brute
et le truand
je vous laisse le choix de dire non je
souffre la musique d'ennio morricone oui
j'aime bien parce que je
les amateurs de western et quand même
les westerns des numéros de café musique
d'ennio morricone
c'est les regarder alors il avait un
oscar pour les salopards et puis il y
avait il était une fois dans l'ouest
fois dans l'ouest ainsi que
l'extraordinaire ordinaire pour que pour
quelques dollars de plus l'armé vers
l'or bon alors sinon il ya une série que
vous voulez conseillé aussi aux
téléspectateurs c'est khalifa oui une
série qu un peu dure série suédoise sur
un sujet qui est vraiment d'actualité
sur l'islamisme et comment des jeunes se
trouvent enrôlé par te faire le
languedoc de myriad et sont complètement
emprisonnés et je trouve qu'elle est
très bien fait avec des acteurs qui
jouent qui joue très bien et c'est
vraiment une dire ça nous apporte
quelque chose cette série explique bien
ce cheminement qui semble
invraisemblable dans des familles
parfaitement intégré où on a justement
en l'occurrence une famille d'immigrés
de première génération totalement
intégré très attaché à la laïcité et qui
est avec des enfants qui se font
doctrine et c'est impressionnant donc
salée et la difficulté du retour après
on voit comment j'avais été marqué sur
ces sujets j'avais fait avec rachida
dati ya quelques années on était allé
faire une visite de prison ensemble sur
des gens qui étaient condamnées pour
radicalisation et pour actes terroristes
et vous voyez la force de
l'endoctrinement et la difficulté qui en
sortir en fait on recense dix ans il y
en a quand même quelques-uns je pense
que le jour ils ressortent et
recommencement mais c'est sur quelle
plateforme saab rigides alors là on ne
peut pas le dire sinon les livres
alors les de ken follett ce sont ces
votre choix aussi
alors qu'est ce que vous avez retenu le
crépuscule et l'eau ça c'est le 4 et le
dernier de la terre c'est le dernier que
je viens de viens de lire c'est un bon
pas vers sa d'ofer 900 pages on est sur
les terres des 12ème siècle
non non on est à voile on est avant on
est avant avant l'an mil
on est avant on est vraiment ce qui va
donner naissance aux cathédrales ensuite
aux piliers de la terre
après sur la construction des
cathédrales c'est l'histoire d'une
princesse normande acea soumises plutôt
plutôt rebelle qui se marient d'amour
avec un prince anglais qui décèdera on
et voilà on est dans était parce que
vous aimez bien voir que je dors bien
quand on est maire depuis quand on était
maire de provins on est sensible aux
médiévales et puis mais ken follett
j'aime bien les romans historiques mais
j'aime bien aussi les romans policiers
qui là qu'il a fait qu'ils sont qui sont
aussi très bon merci inchangé j'étais
avant j'étais fred vargas burger way
avec le commissaire adamsberg merci
christian jacob et de de partager ce
repas avec nous merci jean pierre merci
à vous tous de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve bien sûr la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro de politique à
table
[Musique]